regardez à droite au fond interdit à
toute personne étrangère ça s'appelle
des foyers ce sont des caves des taudis
des chambrés obscures les propriétaires
les gérants ne voulaient pas qu'on
filme vous venez en France pour
travailler ouais ouais est-ce que vous
avez un employeur ici en France il a il
y a tro mon grand frère il est là votre
grand frère est ici vous n'avez pas de
contrat de travail pour la France non
non est-ce que vous avez un billet de
retour ouais ouais où est-il tout ça il
est dans laice il est dans la valise
ouais ouais
bon est-ce que vous avez de l'argent
français sur vous il y a 2000 francs
seulement il est dans la volice pour
mettre transporteur à mon grand frère
c'està-dire 20 nouveaux francs
hein combien de il y a 2000 Fran Fran
seulement 2000 francs anciens et la
France
oui il a certainement vous les avez pas
sur vous hein c'est dans la valise aussi
ouais ouais bon ben on ira les chercher
tout à l'heure voilà on va le mettre de
côté on va le mettre de côté il est à
refoulé sur son point de départ
c'est-à-dire il va retourner à Abidjan
n'ayant pas de contrat de travail pour
pouvoir rester sur notre territoire il
est par conséquent refoulé sur abjan il
y a TR mon grand frère il est là moiil
est arrivé pour trouver de travail et on
vous laissera pas sortir de de Marseille
vous êtes obligé de revenir au pays vous
comprenez comment vous allez faire
alors de
lo vous pouvez pas venir
ici moi est arrivé
pour
depuis 2 ans il en est passé plus de
20000 450 en mai en juin presque aucun
la France le Mali le Sénégal et la
Mauritanie ont signé des accords il faut
un contrat de travail lui n'en a pas
alors il ne sortira pas du bateau dans
de semaines il sera de retour dans le
pays d'où presque tous les autres sont
venus et le pays des saracolet des tout
couleurs dans l'ancienne
AFF c'est la frontière du Mali du
Sénégal et de la Mauritanie une région
d'élevage dans la brousse une des plus
chaudes du globe monsieur Jabir Salou
oui quelle est votre fonction dans le
village ce président secrétaire vous
êtes le président du village village
c'està-dire le le ma le mer oui comment
s'appelle l'endroit où vous êtes assis
c'est assis sur le cora et à quoi sert
la cor dans cor ça le jeuna et le gosse
pour peti réunion de fois c'est c'est
l'endroit où se tiennent les réunions
c'est l'endroit les réunions vous avez
des fils en France je suis deux fils en
France quels sont leurs noms et j'ai
fils qui s'appelle MAM dibira et gai
dibira et que font-ils en France il font
un travail vous ne savez pas quel
travail non ils vous l'ont pas dit non
ils vous écrivent quelque fois si si m'
quelque fois et vous savez pourquoi ils
sont partis je sais pas parce que quand
quand partis m'ach pour partir ils sont
cachés de vous oui ils sont partis sans
vous avertir sans s avertir vous éz pas
content je suis pas
content combien de parents sont partis
en
France qu personnes ont quitté ma
famille pour aller à
Paris
ma ils sont partis parce que à leur âge
chez nous n on on voyage on se promène
on fait du commerce on cherche quelque
chose
mais c'est pas pour autre chose je
crois je suis leur père j'ai voyagé
aussi mais maintenant je cultive je
travaille ici dans le village je ne
bouge
plus leur famille s'oppose à leur départ
leur gouvernement les empêche de sortir
la France les arrête dans ses
etouris n pas
inter vousz de
[Applaudissements]
travail
monsoend en France chez son
cousinouriste quel effet ça vous fait la
France là votre première impression
enfin j'ai l'impression
que de toute
façon si je travaille à Paris si je ne
suis pas paressé et ben je meri une
belle
vie tu mal dormi un peu oui tu eu froid
j'ai pas trop froid al vous avez vu
comment pays je commence à voir
maintenant les revu ça vous plaît sal ça
commence à me plaire I et pourquoi parce
que je trouve que c'est joli jeis jamais
vu encore comme ça c'est ma première
fois tu
VO c'est
beau il le Bruillard vous avez vu le
brouillard tout à l'heure
vu j'ai vu le brouillard tout à l'heure
c'est un beau
paysage et vous êtes habillé là hein
enfin parce que j'ai Frid c'est pour la
bonne raison je me suis habillé comme ça
voyez les camion on arrive à Paris là
ralenti
hein c'est là Paris bientôt
ouais il attendait un taxi devant la
gare de Lyon il tenait une enveloppe à
la main avec une
adresse qui lui avait envoyé la lettre
euh mon grand
frèrec ça le grand frère ou je
m'appelle
commentou
Sénégal non Sénégal Mali
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
pour tout bagage Sandu portait un sac de
papier dedans il y avait un Mollo une
sorte de banjo fabriqué avec une
calebasse un peu
[Musique]
d'Afrique pour
su la France était Saint-Denis rue
Albert
Valter son frère l'attendait
vous êtes content qu'il soit là ah bien
sûr c'est votre premier frère qui est
là
jeune combien vous comptez qu' faut
jours avant qu'il trouve du travail de
TR jours de ou jours ou ou TR jours bien
sûr parce que c'est moi qui les amené
vous log vous logez tous ici je je suis
à
pariszur vous logez ici alors oui moi je
loge ici oui le jeune frère aussi oui je
voulais vous demander est-ce qu' estce
que êes d'accord pour qu'on filme votre
logement parce que nous voudrions
montrer nous voudons montrer comment
votre
logementire pourquoi vous voulez pas
qu'on filme à
l'intérieur ça
[Musique]
vous la caméra sous le bras on est allé
ailleurs la sauvette
regardez à droite au fond interdit à
toute personne
étrangère ça s'appelle des foyers ce
sont des caves des taudis des chambrés
obscures les propriétaires les gérants
ne voulaient pas qu'on filme ils n'ont
pas intérêt à ce qu'on montre comment
ils gagne de l'argent avec la misère ce
sont des Français des Algériens ou des
noirs pour un interview V1 il a fallu le
convoquer à l'écart en
cachette vous êtes le gérant vous du
foyer oui il y a combien de camarad
africain dont vous vous occupez là-bas
il y a 28
228 il paye combien en général 3500 fr
par 3500 franc par mois combien vous
avez de WC dans votre pour les 248
personnes 248 il AC
CC et il y a combien de robinet il doir
attendez attendez 3 4 5 avoir 7 ou ne
[Applaudissements]
VC il font vos camarades font la cuisine
là-bas il font le cing à eumême eu même
il fait la couing entrer il se nourrit
entrer moi je n'a rien à voir làdans au
point de vue logement ils sont en
souslocation et le gérant de la maison
n'est pas souvent le
propriétaire ce gérant prend un bail
avec un
propriétaire lequel après quoi ilci se
ben il vient voir les travailleurs il
leur officiellement il leur donne la
location pour 5000 francs mais après
peut-être il paye 6000 7000 10000 francs
et j'ai visité certains endroits où
vraiment pendant l'hiver il y a même pas
de chauffage ils sont logés ils doivent
acheter eux-mêmes leur propre chauffage
ils n'ont pas d'eau courante ils n'ont
pas d'installation sanitair ils vivent
dans des caves j'ai visité des caves ici
pendant l'hiver vous ça
sointé il y a une question importante je
pense que la plupart des Français se la
posent je demande si c'est pas dans une
certaine mesure de la faute de ces
travailleurs africains s'ils sont mal
logés parce que ils ne consacrent pas
une partie assez important de leur
salaire au logement ils tiennent trop à
faire des économies si vous voulez ah
non là le problème ça ne se pose pas
comme ça milieu africain puisque ces
gens-là quand ils viennent ils cherchent
toujours à être bien logé mais quand ils
arrivent déjà en France ils peuvent
rester 2 à 3 mois ou même 6 mois sans
travail alors là ils ne peutvent vivre
qu'en communauté et quand ils sont sans
travail ils vivent au dépend de leur
communauté et cette nécessité de la
communauté comment la définissez-vous
pour un
Africain cette communauté moi c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de famille
finalement ici ils sont seul ici c'est
exactement comme chez nous dans le temps
colonial les Français quand ils
arrivaient dans nos pays ils se
groupaient dans des clubs ils appelaient
ça Rotary club ou Souan club il trouvait
tous les noms ou tous les soirs toutes
les après-midis il se trouvait là autour
de la féritif et puis se trouva en
Communauté française avant que vous
veniez à Paris oui le grand frère il
avait déjà envoyé des lettres à oui il a
envoyé des lettres beaucoup de lettres
et vous avez au parents il avit expliqué
dans les lettres comment comment a été
la vie à Paris ah oui il a expliqué
qu'est-ce qu'il disait dans ces lettres
alors lui il a dit que dans les lettres
il est en bon état c'est ça qu'il a dit
il est en bon état et travaille mais
est-ce qu'il avait expliqué dans quelles
condition vous seriez logé ici ah non il
n' pas expliqué ça au
parents et pourquoi il a pas expliqué
c'est
pas la chambre était sous un pont de
chemin de faire tu sais il y a une
petite pont de chemin de fer qui quitte
si tu quittes au au porort de kil pour
aller à la mairie sintoine tu sais il y
a un pont qui traverse alors nous étions
sous C pont et combien vous payez pour
par mois 35 3500 francs 3500 francs et
vous étiez combien dans par chambre nous
étiz
15 dès que je suis arrivé ils m'ont dit
maintenant que si tu veux travailler il
faut y aller à Hôtel de ville et si tu
es un PI là-bas ils vont
t'emboucher ils m'ont dit ils vont
t'embucher j'ai dit bon d'accord le
lendemain je suis parti à Hôtel de Ville
le directeur m'a demandé il m'a donné la
plume bon tu peux lire et écrire tu cas
écrire ici sur le cahier je peux lire et
écrire j'écris sur les papi Monsieur le
Directeur je suis venu ici pour chercher
à embaucher et qu'est-ce que vous faites
alors
Comou en Afrique le symbolise la misère
de
l'migré un travail de Madame diton et ce
n'est pas pour ça qu'ils ont traversé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'océan dè 6h du matin devant les usines
il gu
l'embauche souvent on les choisit à
cause de leur vif de leur bonne
musculature parceil par pas encore
français ils sont arrivés la semaine
dernière tu n'as jamais travaillé en
usine gline jamais oui l'usine n pas n
pas il y a pas l'usine en Afrique il n
pas l'usinerique cultivateur làbas
cultivateur
aussi
vous allez embucher beaucoup comm ça ah
Monsieur pardon vous allez embcher
beaucoup ça dépend oui euh aujourd'hui
j'en ai besoin de de trois tu auras le
numéro
487 487 4 87 dis-le 487 4
tu as compris oui alors moi demander à
toi an toi tu dis boulot Bocar oui
numéro 487 oui comment
t'appelles-tu numéro 487 oui faut
toujours dire numéro
dis-luicore moi demander lui lui dit
boulot ba numéro 48
oui boulot po Mangan numéro
44 487
487 c'est bien oui faut toujours dire
numéro hein oui vous le dites pas
combien il va gagner ah ben oui
c'est-à-dire que c'est un problème ça
que je que j'évoque avec eux par la
suite voyez-vous euh mais enfin il
gagnent environ entre 75 80000 francs
par mois alors si tu travailles bien
après tu gagnais plus l'argent hein oui
tu as compris
oui imine
bon écoute toi aussi là hein parce que
tout à l'heure je vais vous prendre
aussi il ne faut pas cracher par terre
[Applaudissements]
hein le 487 n'a pas encore droit aux
machines mais dans 8 jours peut-être le
vieux y africain est apprécié il
convient tout à fait au travail à la
chaîne alors diton il danse plutôt qu'il
ne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
travaille
au début l'opération du pointage crée
des difficultés parce qu'ils ne savent
pas lire mais beaucoup d'entre eux vont
à l'école du soir et bientôt ils
reconnaîtront leur
[Applaudissements]
numéro c'est important pour vous
d'utiliser cette m d'œuvre ben c'est
très important parce que nous trouvons
de moins en moins de main d'œuvre
féminine et si nous ne les avions pas je
ne sais pas très bien comment nous
ferions et vous autres les deux Français
par exemple est-ce que c'est arrivé de
la de la main d'œuvre africaine vous
gêne ou vous gêne pas n gne pas du tout
non du tout du
tout des B camarades on s'entend très
bien avec CZ pas que ça fasse baisser
les salairesune raison étant donné que
la plupart des camarades africains qui
viennent s'ils ne sont pas évidment sont
pas syndiqués mais se syndiqu et ils ont
carrément l'intention de de marcher avec
nous sur sans aucune discrimination
raciale c'est exactement comme si
c'était en parisien ou un Breton après
tout pour nous c'est çaoir des
é bon vous êtes vous employé c'est vrai
des travaux les plus dur pour
beaucoup quelquefois à la sortie des
usines il y a un rassemblement une
petite réunion syndicale noir et blanc
discutent ensemble de leur
salaire les Africains apprennent vite le
prix de leur
travail s' sont venus en France c'est
bien sûr pour ça pour
l'argent alors une augmentation au mois
de Ju une augmentation au mois de
juilletle camarad voilà pour leur dire
là vas-y Disle dis-le
vous gardez à peu près 15000 francs par
mois et vous les envoyez à la
famille parfois on envoie la famille
parfois parce on recevra des lettres
pour envoyer quelque chose parce que il
y a beaucoup leurs parents sont vieux
quoi ils peuvent pas travailler tu es
obligé de les envoyer un peu à manger
c'est ça peut pas le laisser tomber
comme ça nous envoyons l'argent à nos
parents parce que c'est nous qui qui
supporte tous les fraes de la famille et
puis c'est vrai les parents ont de la
nourriture à nourrir là-bas mais
seulement nous cherchons pour vous
cherchez quoi nous cherchons l'argent
pour nourrir la famille parce qu'ils
sont malheureux là-bas au Mali non ils
sont pas malheureux mais pourquoi vous
l' envoyer de l'argent pour qu'il pour
qu'ils achèteent les vaches qu'il
augmentent les troupeaux et que nous
espérons des usines qui font la viande
et chaque fois que nous avyons de
l'argent les troupeaux s'augmentent la
viande aussi
s'augmente le soir une ou deux fois par
mois la veille du départ d'un bateau à
Marseille ou à Bordeaux
il y a fête devant les foyers Boga
Mamadou su repartent au pays il ne reste
jamais plus de de 3 ou 4 ans en
France alors on les accompagne en
taxi et dans de semaines sur le cor du
village ils discuteront après la récolte
du mil Jetta le numéro